whether cool down a little bit yeah like
this I got the nice haircut going I'm
not so slovenly that's a word that's a
big word actually I'm proud of myself
hey what is going on YouTube now from a
social aspect you guys know that when
you get older people say that you have
to drink it means that when you go out
with people the only way that you can
communicate and talk to them freely as
if you have a little alcohol in your
system now for me I've never really
needed that I've always been to ask
myself with without a substance no joke
sometimes I would get like pre rejected
by women you know what that is I would
just inhale and they would say no like
with a [ __ ] em no [ __ ] don't judge a
book by soft and cover squishy on the
outside but there's an abbot there
somewhere but me always being the
designated dumbass I always have a few
things that I hate that drunk people do
I know that you guys have pet piece
because I do too
and guess what [ __ ] LG hi baby
let's get a let's go I said that we're
different number one drum people always
invade your personal space why the [ __ ]
are you always two centimeters from my
[ __ ] nose I'll be Eskimo kissing come
here E and it's never a drunk girl that
invades a guy's personal space that
never [ __ ] happens it's always a dude
that invades another do space those
three centimeters away from my pores of
[ __ ]
inhaling my [ __ ] or AHA [ __ ] how
much garlic did you eat I fail to
understand what alcohol has to do with
you going deaf I drink a little bit I
can't hear anything and this constantly
tends to happen when you go to a party
and the person that you barely know that
you met through your friend now thinks
that you guys are best friends [ __ ] I
don't know you I don't want you around
me and what the [ __ ] is your arm always
on my shoulder do you notice that the
people that invade your [ __ ] space
when they're drunk they always put their
arm over your shoulder like you're look
listen I don't like you and I wish you
were dead
number two people who are habitually
drunk always say they black out that's
funny because I've been drunk before but
even if I had a little bit of a fleeting
memory I would remember about half the
[ __ ] night most people when they get
drunk they like to say that they blacked
out because they don't
to be responsible for the [ __ ] that they
did well guess what [ __ ] I know you
fingered my [ __ ] for that's right
people that usually say they black out
or hiding up the fact that they did
something really stupid nobody told you
to break into a zoo and [ __ ] a frog
nobody told you to put down your pens
and pick that wallet up with your butt
crack
you [ __ ] swine up a human being being
drunk is always an excuse for you to do
stupid [ __ ] I understand that it's a
social lubricant and sometimes some
people need that to go ahead and talk to
new people and gain new experiences but
when you [ __ ] up you should still own to
it that whole black out excuse is really
starting to piss me off oh my god I like
that dudes butthole I can't believe we
blacked out huh no you did it on purpose
and you like butthole like who the [ __ ]
was the first person to accept blacking
out as a legitimate excuse for them to
be a sorry piece of human being you
spineless [ __ ] I hope a zombie horse
eats your dick off yeah number three
while you only got a lot of yourself and
act like you're not throwing up you know
for a fact that you have seven shots of
tequila or shots of Jagermeister three
bears so yes when you're in a moving car
you are going to throw up for some
reason you want to beat that prowl human
being and saying you know what I'm
different I can hold it in no
[ __ ] that's why you stain my
brand-new [ __ ] car now you got to pay
for it and by the way after you barf in
somebody's car you telling them dude I
[ __ ] there you one does not make up
for the fact that you throw up in my
[ __ ] car you have any idea how hard
does get barf out of your car huh the
smell stays forever
it's like shame it doesn't go away just
because you want it to why can't you
drink moderately you do realize that
when you get drunk to a certain point
you're not even funny anymore you just
[ __ ] obnoxious I had this one home
girl every time she got drunk she would
tell everybody that she was gonna get
[ __ ] they're buying the room what
the [ __ ] where [ __ ] is she's a [ __ ]
lesbian what is even true I stand
[ __ ] Chuck come here how we're going
to party waking up with dick in her
mouth every morning on the [ __ ] you live
with yourself
number four drunk people without a doubt
always have to tell you how much they
love you [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know you
the [ __ ] you mean you love me you love
anybody at that moment when you're
intoxicated
are [ __ ] didn't lobby your bro what
would happen if you looked at me you
told me you loved me and I said I love
you back [ __ ] you would cry on the spot
with your emotional myself I don't like
it when drunk people are emotionally
stable because number one they either
tell you way too much [ __ ] that you do
not
want to know or number two they
constantly want to fight people and it's
always the small ones that want to fight
somebody and impress them I'm pretty
sure that oppressing somebody doesn't
include you getting socked in the
[ __ ] teeth you ever get punched so
hard in the face somehow your dick
rolled on them oh my God look at this
you know I'm not gonna lie to you guys I
do drink every now and then I'm not
saying that I enjoy it all the time but
me being a Korean male and me being in
LA and doing all this business sometimes
people like to connect through alcohol I
on the other hand know how to control
myself
I can't drink alcohol when I do I turn
red and everybody calls me kool-aid stop
kool-aid ah [ __ ] you [ __ ] drink
responsibly and just know yourself
before you go ahead and chug a gallon of
beer and for those of you out there that
are young right now what people are
telling you that you have to drink guess
what you don't have to that's your
choice people who think that drinking
makes them into adult or [ __ ] stupid
it's a liquid what you ingest doesn't
make you into a more mature human being
do you realize it if you had an ounce of
intuition or common sense you would know
that getting drunk does not make you
smarter it's like people who tell me
they smoke weed and that they drive
better when they're high [ __ ] no
[ __ ] you think that you're
driving better I know because I'm the
dumbass that went in the car with you
you drove into the ocean a [ __ ]
dolphin popped I said
trial live so